por segundo día la cárcel de latacunga
en la provincia de cotopaxi escenario de
amotinamientos carcelarios El
lanzamiento se inició el día lunes y
hasta la fecha la fiscalía general del
estado informó que ha levantado 15
cadáveres y contabilizados 20 personas
heridas en un país donde la violencia
Cáceres una noticia que se repite
frecuentemente en el paisandino el
gobierno ecuatoriano había informado que
la heces de la tarde del día lunes
contaba con el control del centro
carcelario de latacunga pero nuevas
detonaciones se escucharon en el centro
penitenciario que ocasionó el desarrollo
de familiares la prensa que abordaba lo
sucedido ya hace 24 horas y motivado así
el ingreso de personal militar y un
tanque del ejército a la cárcel ubicada
en la sierra centro de Ecuador las
autoridades no han emitido el informe
oficial por el nuevo amotinamiento 8
masacres se registran en Ecuador desde
el año 2021 en su mayoría por el control
de territorio que ha generado una guerra
sin precedentes por los reclusos en
distintas cárceles del país que se
produjeron el mes de febrero Julio
septiembre noviembre del año 2021
mientras que los que va de año 2022 se
han producido en el mes de abril mayo
julio y octubre contabilizando 366
personas asesinadas dentro de las cá